in five days wait
see some cool
right behind you
it's the single greatest superhero movie
ever made
hey youtubers it's Charlie so some new
badass Black Panther footage Captain
America Civil War dropping this week if
you haven't seen it yet make sure you
tell them to shut up and take my money
Chadwick Boseman is to chaka is going to
be one of the most awesome things ever
no spoilers for the movie if you have
seen it you know please don't post
spoilers in the comments but the
interesting thing with his character
like the interesting challenge that they
had is that they didn't want him to be
this caricature because his name is
Black Panther so they were just like a
million ways that this could have gone
wrong and only a couple ways that could
have gone right and they've completely
nailed the character thus far and the
really interesting thing that that
Marvel does with its movies that you
don't really get to do with a lot of
other movies is that while they were
working on Civil War stuff they were
also developing the Black Panther movie
so the director of the Black Panther
movie was able to inform his performance
the Black Panther performance during
civil war like the Russos brought in the
director of Black Panther to help them
with their Black Panther scenes in civil
war just to make sure that there was
consistency in the character between
this movie in the Black Panther movie
and yeah they're introducing him to the
universe in this movie so it's a really
big deal but I think just for this
character the Black Panther movie is way
more important so of course if you're
using that character in someone else's
movie you want the person that's like
really writing the definitive take on
the character to be involved so you just
really don't get that opportunity with a
lot of other movies like sometimes
they'll hire other directors to consult
like Steven Spielberg came on to consult
during the Star Wars prequels a little
bit but it's not really the same thing
as Marvel making its movies it's a
completely new situation and totally
fascinating even just looking at the
trailer footage you get this real sense
that he has this regal bearing it just
commands your respect he's every bit the
equal of the Winter Soldier and Captain
America regardless of where their powers
flow from they just do a really good job
of balancing this like it could go one
of two ways really when you talk about a
fight like Winter Soldier versus Black
Panther the person who wins is just
gonna be the person who wants it more
because just taking is there presented
in this movie they're equal fighters so
really the only way to let one beat the
other is to put one at a disadvantage
and I think that's what the movie does
at certain points but that's kind of an
issue with the other characters too like
Captain America versus Iron Man like how
do you let them face off without making
one look like a complete idiot so mass
respect to the Russos for being able to
pull this off in a believable way I
can't really talk about it without
getting into spoilers but
been talking a little bit about the next
Ironman Phillip Robert Downey jr. has
just been like hey you know maybe maybe
I got one more movie and me just like
winking at us from behind all of his
cameras like yeah I could totally stick
around to do another movie the rumor is
is that spider-man is largely going to
influence the direction that movie is
going to take but they haven't really
said anything official yet Marvel itself
hasn't said yeah we're totally going to
be doing a new Iron Man film I think
everybody behind the scenes is just kind
of testing audience reaction like would
they like the idea of a new Iron Man
film the answer of course is a
resounding yes like please give us
another Iron Man film if you've seen the
movie then you probably totally
understand what they mean when they say
spider-man's relationship with Iron Man
could totally inspire this new Iron Man
film but we can get into specifics when
I start doing spoilery Civil War videos
I'm not gonna be posting my first review
that'll be like a non-spoilery one till
Thursday
I'll start posting Easter eggs on Friday
I would say by Thursday most of you like
at least 50% of the people in the world
that are gonna see the movie will
probably have seen it I know there's a
lot of confusion about why movies come
out earlier some places than other
places the reason that a lot of big
movies get released internationally
before they get released in the US
nowadays is because one it helps curb
international piracy that's always been
a big problem for Studios where it's
like you know people outside the United
States are like hey we want to see this
really awesome movie but you're not
going to release it in our country so
we're gonna pirate it so screw you guys
so it's an answer to that and to the
second big reason is that the
international markets are now much more
important to the financial success of
big movies than ever before like the
international box office for a lot of
these big movies is sometimes sixty
percent of the total revenue for a movie
so even though people still talk about
box office really the international box
office is a more important number than
the domestic box office and I'm just
talking about films that are largely
thought of as American films so if you
haven't seen it already or if you have
seen it and you want to see it again
everybody just be sure to go see it this
week because we will be talking a whole
lot about it
just to celebrate I'm doing an IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's a gift
certificate for the value of two imax
tickets so I'll just leave the giveaway
open through all my Marvel videos this
week so I'll just I'll remind people
that there is a ticket giveaway going on
the next time I post a Marvel video if
you're big Game of Thrones fan will be
talking about a few things specifically
this week there
just like a couple really big things
that we're all gonna be talking about
this week so if you're not up on Game of
Thrones now's the time to catch up if
you guys haven't seen it yet you can
click here for last night's episode of
Game of Thrones big amazing wonderful
things happen and you can click here for
my spider-man Civil War video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight